after considerable agony we've left a
relationship we're on our own now and
when we can bear to be honest it is a
little bit harder than we expected we
aren't going on so many dates the
central heating broke down last week
the shopping is proving a hurdle in idle
moments we find ourselves daydreaming
returning fondly to certain occasions in
the recently concluded relationship
there was that wintry weekend by the sea
they looked adorable walking on the
beach in a thick scarf we fed seagulls
and drank cheap wine from paper cups on
the seafront and felt connected and
happy when newly conscious of the charm
of so many things that seemed ordinary
at the time coming out of the
supermarket putting everything away in
the fridge in the cupboards making soup
and toasted cheese and watching TV on
the sofa with these thoughts in mind we
feel weepy and tender and at points
distinctly tempted to call the ex up
again they would we suspect allow us
back or at least give us a hearing what
can we make of our feelings it might be
that we have realized a genuine mistake
but it's even more likely that we are in
the grip of a characteristic mental
habit of the newly single facing the
vertigo of Independence nostalgia in the
middle of the 19th century Britain
underwent industrial and scientific
revolutions that transformed old settled
ways of life ripping apart communities
throwing people together in large and
anonymous cities and dislocating the
loyalties and certainties once offered
by religion in a search for ways to
soften the confusion artists and
thinkers began to imagine what a better
world might look like and in certain
circles the search turned towards the
past and more specifically towards the
perceived wisdom coherence and
contentment of the Middle Ages
while railway lines were being laid down
across the land and Telegraph cables
under the Seas members of the artistic
class celebrated the simple innocent
communities that they proposed had
existed in the 12th and 30
centuries artworks depicted handsome
uneducated but happy laborers cheerful
villagers celebrating harvests and
kindly lords and ladies ministering to
the deserving poor there seemed to be no
violence alienation fear or cruelty
no one minded not having much heating or
subsisting on a meager diet of oats in
the odd piece of lard it had it was
alleged been very much easier back then
in the fast cottages and pious stone
churches at the heart of the nostalgic
attitude is a disregard for why things
ever changed and might have needed to do
so for the nostalgic the past never
required alteration or development
history moved on but for no sane reason
the complexities of the present moment
are in this sense deemed wholly
accidental they are not the tricky
byproducts of a legitimate search for
growth and progress away from what must
have been at some level despite the odd
delightful occasion perhaps at harvest
time or on a midsummer morning an
intolerable previous arrangement the
nostalgic can't accept that the present
whatever its faults came about because
of inescapable difficulties with the
past they insist that we had already
once been perfectly happy then
mysteriously changed everything for the
worse
because we forgot we had been so
relationships can find us reasoning no
less selectively here too it can feel as
if we must once have been content and
then grew ungrateful through error and
inattention yet in locating profound
satisfaction in the past we are
crediting our earlier selves with too
little acumen the truth about what a
relationship is like is best ascertained
not when we are feeling low six months
or a few years after its conclusion but
from what we must have known when we
were in its midst when we were most
familiar with all the facts upon which
we made our slow and deliberate decision
to leave the specific grounds for our
disaster
actions tend to evaporate we edit out
the rouse the botched trips the sexual
frustrations the stubborn standoffs the
mind is a squeamish organ it doesn't
like to entertain bad news unless there
is a highly present danger to be
attended to but knowing our amnesiac
tendencies we can be certain that
profound unpleasantness must have
existed for there would otherwise have
been no explanation for on our decision
to rip a relationship apart we would
never have needed to act if things had
ever remotely been as gratifying as we
are now nostalgic ly assuming they were
the portrait we are painting of our
relationship is emerging not from
knowledge but from loneliness and
apprehension furthermore our sense of
ourselves as people who could be
satisfied with what was on offer is as
untrue to our own nature as is the
fantasy of a modern urban dweller who
dreams they might find enduring
happiness in a medieval-style wooden hut
the solution to the problem of
satisfying our needs is not to
hallucinate that they don't exist it is
to square up to them and use every
ingenuity we're capable of to devise
workable solutions for them we should
trust not what we feel now in our weepy
disconsolate state but what we must have
known then a simple rule of thumb
emerges we must invariably trust the
decisions we took when we had the
maximal information to hand upon which
we made them not when we have emotional
incentives to change our minds and mould
ourselves into a caricature of an easily
gratified creature there were persuasive
reasons even if in our sadness we now
can't remember a single one returning to
the past wouldn't make us content it
would merely add great cost to all
involved remind us of why change was in
the end so necessary we need to accept
that good things did exist
but that there were no proper solution
to certain of our well-founded needs it
means accepting that we are as
complicated and as difficult to satisfy
as we are and that the way forward is to
accept our characters rather than assume
a simplicity we could never live up to
we should have the courage of and be
ready to pay the full price for our true
complex natures
love is a skill that we can learn our
relationships book calmly guides us with
calm and charm through the key issues of
relationships to ensure that success in
love need not be a matter of good luck
for more click the link now